et comment la maladie se manifeste dans
les poumons comment les poumons effecté
réagi style pourquoi sommes nous si
impuissants j'en parle avec docteur jean
françois lisée pneumologue intensiviste
au service des soins intensifs du shbo
soit d'actualiser merci d'être là pour
nous bonsoir insurgés plaisir oui je
vais quand même donner les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien le
tableau parce que dans ces chiffres on a
quand même 1629 cas de gens contaminés
huit morts mais ya que 106
hospitalisations pour le moment là qu'on
a quand même six mille lits disponibles
mais parmi les 106 cas il ya 43 code de
soins intensifs soit d'actualiser sa
rejoint le profil des patients que vous
soignez alors peut-être nous dire
docteur lisez un peu qu'est ce qui se
passe dans les poumons les autres
voyages qu'on a pu entendre au fil des
jours c'est à quel point ça faisait mal
dans les poumons
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien en fait
le corno virus qui est responsable de la
copie la pandémie convient actuellement
d'un virus connu des québécois presque
10% des rhumes qu'on subit l'hiver
habituellement son duo au covan au virus
cependant ce coronavirus la lutte des
mutations est une forme qui causent
effectivement une maladie sévère chez
une certaine proportion de patients on
parle parfois jusqu'à 15 % des patients
hospitalisés qui développe un syndrome
aigu de détresse respiratoire et ses
patients le effectivement au besoin
d'aller aux soins intensifs et souvent
d'être mis sur respirateur
alors c'est l'inhalation du virus si les
russes se tient dans des petites
particules des petites gouttelettes qui
sont inhalées par un autre système
respiratoire se rend jusque dans nos
poumons et le virus va rentrer dans nos
cellules pulmonaires et vont les
détruire et causé une réaction
inflammatoire du système immunitaire
vaut réagir à ça et c'est un peu le
virus est la réaction de notre système
immunitaire qui est un peu le sens bâle
et va causer une inflammation énorme
dans les poumons et vous posez une
pneumonie sévère des deux poumons et
c'est les deux poumons qui vont souffrir
complètement de cette inflammation là et
qu'il est la gradation de la maladie
parce que et plusieurs gens sont à la
maison
tendu des gens sont hospitalisés sans
nécessairement loin elle est aux soins
intensifs
ça serait comment le passage que ce qui
arrive au compass de lit d'hôpital
est ce que dans un simple lit d'hôpital
on a déjà de l'assistance avec oxygène
ou seulement aux soins intensifs
alors effectivement la force d' attaque
du virus peut varier
agen des symptômes comme vous habitez
creed de fièvre toux rhinorrhée donc
écoulements nasaux et également douleurs
musculaires on sent vraiment un bon
jusqu'à même une bonne grippe on
pourrait dire et ça peut aller jusqu'à
est hospitalisé avec de l'oxygène
effectivement et il le virus peut aller
jusqu'à nous en aux soins intensifs est
mis sous respirateur et une respiration
artificielle
pourquoi les gens ont différents types
de symptômes et de sévérité
ces programmes a dû à des facteurs
génétiques on sait que les patients plus
âgés
on sait que les patients atteints de
maladies chroniques qui présente déjà
une étude de santé fragile sont plus à
risque de développer une sévérité chez
cette tautologie
on a vu des jeunes aussi on sait que des
jeunes à la trentaine d'adolescents qui
est mort
a los angele donc s'attaque aussi des
jeunes est ce que c'est parce qu'il va
pas s qui fume on sait pas trop donc ce
serait génétique
c'était imprévisible il n'y a pas de
traitement haute que l'assistance
respiratoire c'est ça actuellement il
n'y a pas de traitement effectivement il
ya des jeunes possiblement que ces
personnes-là pourrait peut-être avoir
une génétique plus favorable au virus
actuellement le virus est à nouveau il
est différent de celui qu'on a connu
dans les épidémies de 2003 du strass
alors ce virus à nouveau on n'a pas les
réponses à ces questions là mais ce
qu'il serait possible que ces gens là
avaient peut-être une prédisposition
génétique
peut-être peut-être c'est certainement
pour relier en tout cas où va potage
actuellement sont garantis il ya grand
débat entourant l'accessibilité aux
masques les je pense que l'assistance
respiratoire on avait neuf sans
équipement est selon vous est ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a ce qu'il faut
quand on entend le gouverneur de new
york crios coup avoir des ventes il est
ce que c'est de ce défunt dont on a
besoin les ventilateurs c'est
l'équipement dont vous avez besoin c'est
la même chose ou pas oui effectivement
on a besoin de respirateurs pour
l'écossé vert ou soins intensifs ça
c'est clair
je peux vous dire que le meilleur le
meilleur traitement ou en fait le
meilleur chose qu'on peut faire dans une
pandémie comme ceux de virus c'est la
prévention et c'est exactement ce que
les autorités publiques ont fait et le
gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise et je pense qu'on espère avec sa
déjà d'avoir réduit la propagation du
virus
par la suite les gens qui seront
atteints on sera prêt le système de
santé à faire face à la musique si vous
me permettez l'expression
tous les hôpitaux actuellement sont en
état d' alerte tous les outils soient
intentions vous aussi l'autre aussi chez
nous s'ils sont en état d' alerte on est
prêt en avions mis stimulation en
avez-vous des patients actuellement
actuellement au québec il ya des
patients dans pratiquement tous les
hôpitaux l'un capable de s'occuper de
patients 30 il y est il capable de
s'occuper de patients malades comme ceux
de la coved 19 quand vous dites vente
utilise avec le respirer dans theater
respirateur ça même chose oui oui
françois respirateur sommes tous aient
la même journée pourquoi les hommes
davantage
c'est une très bonne question est-ce
qu'ils ont une prédisposition génétique
là aussi on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement
les hommes sont attaqués
60% à 65% des cas alors c'est une
question je peux pas vous répondre
actuellement une observation ont fait
exactement
est-ce que tout à l'heure je parlais des
tips le choix était fan telli est ce que
vous craignez vous un jour de devoir
choisir entre un patient âgé au moins
aux plus jeunes
je vous dirais que c'est toujours une
crainte
on note quand on parle de pandémie
cependant les tendinites 40 niveaux
d'attac de la population et à ce sujet
il ya plusieurs équipes le groupe de 60
des tic d'un médecin un pic en
pneumologie et autres qui travaillent
actuellement des scénarios pour
peut-être avoir des lignes directrices
qui pourraient être adoptées par les
autorités de la santé publique
mais je peux vous dire qu'actuellement
on est très loin de cette situation tant
mieux parce qu'on nous a dit que si on
est en phase d'accélération puis que
dans trois semaines on va être dans le
pic alors on s'intéresse à son va tout
simplement avoir à se reparler
une dernière question une fois qu'on
passe en soins intensifs on n'y est pas
combien de temps en moyenne combien
temps reste malade alors les durées de
séjour aux soins intensifs ont analysé
les données qui viennent d'italie entre
autres de france évidemment de chine dac
or et c'est extrêmement variable à durée
moyenne de séjour aux soins intensifs de
et de près de 8 à 10 jours
cependant on accuse souvent les décès
dans ces statistiques
ce qu'on a de façon préliminaire c'est
que la durée de séjour aux soins
intensifs c'est un patient qui survit
pour aller le fascinant entre dix et
quinze jours et parfois même se
prolonger
on guérit alors en cinq ans et et guérir
oui les gens peuvent guérir cette
maladie même si ce qui est positif
alors je peux vous dire que nous le
système de santé québécois et les soins
intensifs du québec on est prêt et on
sera là pour répondre à vos questions
puis traiter les patients merci
d'actualiser de l'espoir de l'espoir de
l'espoir merci beaucoup merci à vous et
à tous les soignants à toutes vos
équipes
merci d'être sur la ligne de front et
prendre les laisse sans nous merci